[Music]
since cena warrior princess ran for six
seasons it won't come as much of a
surprise to find that the writers
occasionally push their hero to some
pretty dark places the fantasy series
pits cena against all manner of monsters
and villains while she attempts to atone
for her violent past although xena
warrior princess was a fun action-packed
adventure the show often took some
unpleasant turns in season four for
example the villain callisto is released
from a fiery dimension by the king of
hell who wants to corrupt xena back into
her old ways and from there the whole
story gets kinda dark after kalisto
promises the king of hell that she will
corrupt xena the hero winds up in prison
alongside her companion gabrielle
kalisto had broken xena's spine using
the iconic chakram at her back leaving
her completely powerless and although
gabrielle fights off a cohort of roman
soldiers for a while she eventually
surrenders later both she and xena are
crucified together the actual
crucifixion scene is a tough watch for
audiences it may not be gratuitously
gory but it's certainly intense and
according to lucy lawless who played
zena it was equally tormenting to make
when discussing the series with
entertainment weekly lawless explained
the horrific crucifixion scene was
filmed in the dead of winter in new
zealand the actress said it is hands
down my least favorite way to die i've
been crucified several times and it's
never good the xena star added it's
always really windy and really miserable
and you're up hanging from a cross for
hours lawless went on to reveal that it
was scenes like this that had sapped all
her energy by the time the series came
to an end she said i thought it ended at
the right time i was struggling through
that last year because it was relentless
it was nine months a year i was out of
gas by the end it kicked my ass and sure
zena and gabrielle's crucifixion it's
pretty rough going but it's not the only
time the show has pushed the envelope
with its content during an interview
with entertainment weekly zena
co-creator robert tappert revealed that
the higher ups only occasionally stepped
in and asked production to tone
something down one of those times was
for a scene in the season one finale is
there a doctor in the house the episode
finds xena and gabrielle bringing their
friend efforty an amazon warrior who is
about to give birth to ascend to our
baby to a healing tumble in the midst of
a terrible war ethany's sudden labor is
already ill-timed but when xena realizes
that the centaur baby is breached she
knows she has to act swiftly and deliver
the child via cesarean section it's
breach
we'll have to cut it down what if she
can't deliver the baby and she will die
tapat told entertainment weekly we had
this terribly gross caesarean birth of a
baby centaur from a woman they said the
advertisers will pull out and we did it
anyways in the end one particular
advertiser did refuse to appear
alongside a realistic centaur c-section
leading to the scene having to be toned
down according to tapers they said oh
eminem's is pulling out and we have to
recut of course while crucifixions and
emergency surgeries are pretty grisly
there's another infamous scene that
still stokes controversy to this day in
this season 3 episode the bittersweet
xena and gabrielle's relationship is at
a low ebb after gabrielle inadvertently
causes the death of zena's son under
normal circumstances the pair might have
found a healthy way to resolve this
conflict however before that could
happen god of war ares visits xena and
encourages her to go down a path of
vengeance against her friend influenced
by ares xena tracks down gabrielle and
proceeds to tie her to the back of her
horse and have her violently dragged
along the ground even compared to the
show's other dark moments this one is a
doozy not least because it's so hard to
watch one of television's best pairings
get torn apart so ruthlessly and so very
violently
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]